good evening ghosts it's been 20 years
since the release of the original tom
clancy's ghost recon all the way back in
2001.
since then we've released 15 titles
across pc console and portable devices
and with each game we've been able to
watch the ghost recon franchise grow and
evolve into the tactical open world
action epic we know and love today
but we're not going to let an
anniversary like this pass without
getting a little nostalgic about a
franchise that's close to our hearts and
hopefully yours too
we'll be looking back at two decades
worth of ghost recon games as well as a
look at the present day post-launch
efforts with ghost recon break point and
it wouldn't be a birthday party without
a few presents so be sure to stay tuned
to the very end for news on free content
and a few other surprises too so whether
you're a new recruit who's just
discovered the series or a seasoned
veteran who's been with us from day one
we hope you'll join us for a bullet
riddle trip down memory lane
to kick things off i'd like to hand you
over to ericusion creative director on
ghost recon future soldier ghost recon
wildlands and ghost recon break point
hey ghosts i'm eric cosian and i'm
creative director on the ghost recon
franchise as someone who started out as
designer and costa rican adventure
fighter back in 2004 i'm both honored
and excited to be able to celebrate this
special milestone with you
working on a franchise with a legacy
like ghost record we have to stay true
to the roots of the franchise
firstly wide open areas ever since the
original ghost recon in 2001
the coast have always excelled in open
environments and secondly when it comes
to story we've always taken great care
to follow in the footsteps of tom clancy
every game we make is a kind of what-if
scenario and finally
authenticity is the cornerstone of our
brand
especially when it comes to the ghosts
and the tactical options they have
over the past few years we've had the
opportunity to collaborate with very
talented people
creating a ghost recon game is a
question of passion but i'd like to take
a special moment to wish everyone who
has worked on or played the ghost recon
game over the last two decades the happy
20th
anniversary thank you all the ghosts out
there
and now let's dive into how we create
the words of ghost recon with benoit
world director
[Music]
hi ghost my name is benoit martinez my
personal history with the franchise
dates back 20 years ago to the original
ghost record which i bought with my very
first paycheck true story years later i
joined the ghost recon team to work on
future soldier
the game was mostly linear apart from a
couple of levels made by our friends at
the buchara studio
those stages were more open and somehow
closer to the original dr experience
after we released the game we started to
experiment further with this idea first
we tried one square kilometer it was
quite big compared to what we've done
previously and we were surprised that
the old game engine we were using could
even handle it then we doubled the size
and it worked so we doubled again and
again
after a week we were working with the
biggest terrain we'd ever created it was
literally a thousand square kilometer
way too big for an actual game but we
were just prototyping at that stage and
it was super exciting not to mention
absolutely crazy
to meet our ambitions we also had to
find the perfect setting
we considered many options but
ultimately
we all agreed on bolivia because of all
the incredible landscapes
we sent the number of teams to many
different sites to gather as much
reference material as we could we've
been on the death road twice back and
forth
all the places you can see in the game
are inspired by relocation including my
favorite the laguna colorada with all
the flamingos but moving from a linear
game to an open world was also a huge
challenge from both design and a
technical perspective
it was new for us to build things of
this scale at each step we were amazed
by how crazy it was but also how nicely
everything was coming together
i remember the first time we had the
vehicle in the game we all spent the day
just driving around racing against each
other and discovering the world from a
new perspective that's why world
building is such a fascinating job every
day there's something new and every day
and ideas become reality
over the years i've been fortunate to
work with an incredible team of
passionate artists and designers some of
whom have been with the franchise since
advanced warfighter it's been amazing to
see the dedication of the team and how
willing they are to improve the game
explore new territories and push the
limits of what ghost recon can be
thank you eric and benoit the ghost
recon series has a number of defining
features sprawling maps white knuckle
gun fights and tactical flexibility to
name just a few
but one of the key elements that keeps
gamers coming back for more is the
painstaking attention to detail that
goes into a ghost recon game every gun
every gadget every last pixel that makes
the battlefield feel so real our next
two ghosts have a long history not just
with the ghost recon series but with red
storm entertainment and the tom clancy
video game brand so please welcome
richard danske and travis goetz
hi ghost i'm travis i'm the senior
authenticity coordinator on the ghost
recon series
i've always been interested in military
people history and equipment since i was
a kid so it's been an honor to work on a
series where authenticity is the
lifeblood of the games
we've always encouraged teams to invest
a lot of time and resources into making
sure ghost recon feels authentic so that
means setting up meetings with elite
special forces operatives making sure
that teams have the very best reference
when it comes to reproducing equipment
and also keeping an eye out for
technologies and new tactics can be
really important about 20 years ago we
even created a gear room that is full of
thousands of pieces of real-life
military gear these are there so artists
and animators can check out the real
thing and help get those fine details
just right this is actually my office
the games always change but the core
remains the same
giving players an authentic look into
the world of the real-life special
forces and to tell you a bit more on how
we craft those stories i'll turn things
over to rich
[Music]
my name is richard danske and i'm the
central clancy writer for ubisoft
to write a ghost recon story you start
by looking at the news not necessarily
the front page stuff but look for
conflicts that would be appropriate for
the ghosts
addition to that global flavor you also
want to have a clear and present danger
there has to be a reason this elite band
of operators is getting sent in after
all
then there's the high tech aspect the
ghosts not only are the best they've got
the best gear
then there's believability it has to
feel like something could be on the news
otherwise you don't have a military
shooter you've got a science fiction
ghost recon storytelling has always
relied heavily on authenticity
ranging from
gut checking character bios to sitting
down with real world operators and
hearing their stories i'm very proud of
the work i've done on various ghost
recon projects it almost feels like
ghost recon and i have grown up in the
industry together and i want to see it
continue for many more years
[Music]
as you can probably tell by now we've
come a long way
we couldn't have made it to where we are
today without the hard work and
dedication of ghosts like richard travis
and the rest of the team at red storm
entertainment
but all that hard work would have been
for nothing if it wasn't for you the
fans who've made ghost recon more than a
series of games 20 years for the fans
with the fans we know that without our
community we wouldn't have made it past
our first title never mind to 20 years
so with that in mind we're happy to
announce a little something to say thank
you we're giving you the chance to go
right back to where it all started with
the very first ghost recon absolutely
free to download and keep on ubisoft
connect
and that's not all
for all you wildlands players out there
we're granting you free access to the
fallen ghost dlc on ps4 xbox and pc we
hope you enjoy seeing just how far the
ghost recon brand has come over the last
20 years and that you're as excited as
we are for the future of the franchise
but now to the present day
in this next section of the showcase i'd
like to hand over to some of the people
who've been working on ghost recon
breakpoint since launch to make sure
that it reaches expectations our fans
have for a ghost recon game
[Music]
my name is xavier
our production team has worked
hand-in-hand with our community team
listening to the players fixing issues
and improving the experience with
exciting new gameplay teachers when
breakpoint launched we wanted players to
experience the feeling of being alone
and abandoned in a north style
environment
but we quickly realized that working as
an elite unit is something that long
time fans of the franchise believe his
core to the ghost recon experience
that's why we brought back the ai
teammate to back you up on your mission
since the skin tree was originally
intended for the player character we had
to find a way to use it for leveling up
your ai teammates it took a bit of
creative problem solving on our part but
all that hard work has opened the door
to all kinds of new features if you need
an example of how far breakpoint has
come look no further than the ghost
experience we realized that many of the
players want different things from a
ghost recon game some players want a
more tactical immersive military
simulation experience that can be played
solid others want to drop in and have
fun with a trend in the morning
in the original release
many players found it hard to fully
commit to a stealth build because they
kept getting spotted by enemy drones or
other cities guards
but with the custom difficulty sliders
players were able to remove drones from
enemy cams and with the new brethren
feature they could distract enemies or
draw guards away from the rest of the
pack for silent takedown
one of the features we're the most proud
of is the ability to play the game with
a friend with using completely different
difficulty settings all at the same time
and without unbalancing the experience
for either player
we're always searching for unique and
interesting military gear that we can
incorporate into any new content we're
releasing we work together to identify
some of the most highly requested items
from our players what have we had the
most requests for guidehoods
and we've integrated them into the
latest teammate update experience so
keep an eye out for them in the game key
to our post-launch plans has been to add
an extra layer of hard qa testing to
provide the best experience with the new
features we're adding
nowadays there are so many platforms and
specs that need to be tested so it's
good for the production team to know
they have a dedicated team playing the
game testing new content and tracking
how breakpoint is performing for players
no matter what hardware they are playing
on those early difficulties we have
they have helped us to gain a better
understanding of what is the core of a
ghost recon game a customizable team of
elite operatives given the freedom to
approach objectives however they choose
all endorphins by an unmatched sense of
realism it's always a joy to know that
millions of players are having fun with
something that myself and the team at
ubisoft have worked so hard on and i'm
really excited to hear more from you
about the new content we have in the
pipeline
from myself on the rest of the team at
ubisoft paris we want to send a big
thank you to the community of fans
across the world for inspiring us to
make ghost recon breakpoint the game we
always knew it could be
[Music]
thanks to everyone for your continued
hard work as you've heard by now our
fans play a key role in our plans for
ghost recon break point but for us
community doesn't just mean voice chat
and message boards we want to empower
players to showcase their creativity
their skills and their love for all
things ghost recon
that's why we created delta company our
community leaders program through which
we empower you the community in sharing
your passion for our game
but don't just take our word for it why
not hear it straight from delta company
themselves
[Music]
i was lucky enough uh to hear about uh
this program called delta company i've
never seen that before uh
a game where the community helped build
it
i'd like to wish you a happy 20-year
anniversary to all my girls out there i
spent most of my time on ghostwriting
phantoms then came wildlands which
redefined the franchise for me i will
thank the team for communicate with the
community to communicate with the delta
company and put so much hard work so i
hope i get another 20 years experience
in ghost recon who knows where it's
going to go next but keep on keeping on
and thank you
[Music]
thank you for all of the hard work time
and love you've invested into ghost
recon we really appreciate your support
and dedication to the series
to show our thanks for your continued
support we thought we'd give you a sneak
peek at what's next for the ghosts and
for arowa with a brand new trailer for
our next major title update introducing
operation motherland
[Music]
nomad
this is bowman
been a long time
[Music]
the cia has been covertly working with
the outcasts and their leader haruhi ito
to declare arowa a free and autonomous
nation
operation motherland will begin the
moment you meet up with nito at the
outcast camp
good luck
and try not to get killed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can't wait for you to get your hands on
this new update in the meantime the
celebration and gifts are not over to
celebrate this 20th anniversary iconic
skins past games will be included in the
next update for all players to get for
free and that's not all for all you
ghost recon break point players you'll
be able to unlock the entire deep state
adventure for free that's pretty much
all for me i'd like to thank you all
once more for joining us and celebrating
20 years of ghost recon it bears
repeating we wouldn't have made it here
without you so thank you from everyone
at ubisoft but before i go there's just
one more thing that we'd like to share
with you
while the paris studio keeps working to
support and improve break point we have
another studio working on a top secret
ghost recon project
[Music]
[Music]
hello ghosts my name is razvan and i'm a
community developer at ubisoft bucharest
myself and the team here in bucharest
are excited to finally share what we've
been working on for the past three years
let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
cause i'm
[Music]
this is an epidemic of the vultures in
the playpen resource with a smile and a
cow that leaves
politicians
evil be that evil bold
this is
[Music]
[Applause]
we hope you enjoyed the trailer and this
very first look at our next game
frontline is a brand new installment in
the franchise taking the tactical
heritage of ghost recon and expanding
upon it within a large scale pvp
experience where you choose how you want
to win
now i'd like to pass the mic to the rest
of the team who are eager to tell you
more about our vision behind the project
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to bucharest and
the world reveal of a brand new
experience in the ghost recon universe
tom clancy's ghost recon frontline is an
exciting new addition within the
franchise driven by our very personal
take on a military authentic massive pvp
shooter
we are bringing you a tactical action
game with a dynamically evolving pace
and freedom of approach at its core
in ghost recon frontline you are at the
heart of the action and it's up to you
to decide how you're going to out think
out maneuver and outplay your opponents
because in this combat zone there's
always more than one path to victory
jumping into the game is simple just
choose a contractor pick a game mode and
get to it
progression comes from improving your
expertise with different weapons
completing objectives and unlocking new
recruits for your team
contractors will be generated from a
pool of various nationalities military
origins looks and classes
each with their own specialization
development paths and loadouts to
benefit your team
classes are highly specialized filling
in distinct tactical roles the assault
for example provides great
sustainability in close range fights and
overall proficiency in offensive
maneuvers
the support class can offer superior
protection thanks to their fortification
abilities that will let you defend your
position much easier while the scout can
easily recon the area for their team
revealing and pestering your enemies
from a distance without fear of reprisal
these are just three examples of what
we're planning to be available at launch
with more to be added during seasonal
updates
the soldiers you choose will radically
shape how your team progresses and
accomplishes goals no two players will
have the same faith so you must think
fast on your feet and adapt to the
situation at hand ghost recon frontline
is about complete strategic freedom in
our flagship mode called expedition
players are dropped onto the island of
drakemore in three person squads tasked
with finding crucial intel scattered
across the landscape drakemore is a vast
open world filled with distinct biomes
and landmarks to explore
that's a good thing because there'll be
more than 100 players active at once
all vying for the same intel
once you're done collecting it's time to
head to a drop zone and call for an
extraction
now here's where it gets really tense
extraction is quite noisy every team on
the island will see your position and
will be gunning for your ride if they
intercept you before you successfully
extract they can steal it and use it for
their own how you will try the wind is
entirely up to you gather intel and
extract in a hail of bullets or lie and
wait for another team's extraction and
play the spoiler
this is just the tip of the iceberg when
it comes to the freedom you have in
setting your own objectives and shaping
the game your way ensuring that no match
will play the same
frontline is still a ghost recon game
built on its core values this means it's
gameplay it's all about creating your
own solutions to overcome different
situations
we've brought it into a first person
perspective to heighten your immersion
and retailer the core mechanics from the
ground up to emphasize reactivity
everything from the way you move to the
way your gun handles feels faster
sharper and more responsive all of this
to provide a seamless and satisfying
experience while expedition will be our
flagship mode and the heart of frontline
there will be other more casual options
added for those who want to get some
quick access traditional arena shooter
experience or simply test their new
ideas for loadout class composition or
technical support setup we'll be rolling
out a suit of unique modes to allow
player greater variety in gameplay
options as our game world evolves with
each season
no matter what your preference is we are
committed to making sure this title has
something for everyone as huge fans of
pvp shooters our team knows that
creating a balanced and fun experience
requires a lot of testing and iteration
based on players feedback without your
involvement it simply cannot happen
that's why we don't just want to hear
your feedback we want you to see how it
affects our journey to deliver the most
polished and entertaining experience
possible you'll be able to put your
tactical preparation to the test in tom
clancy ghost recon frontline soon
registration for our upcoming tests are
now open and i'm thrilled to let you
know that many of you will be able to
play the game in our european pc close
test with other platforms to be
announced at a later phase
make sure to sign up to this link to get
more info and a chance to play the game
keep in mind frontline is still in early
development but because of this you the
players have a chance to shape the
experience before its final release
so if you want to help decide the
direction for this exciting new chapter
in the ghost recon saga be sure to sign
up for the upcoming closed test there
will be plenty more from ghost recon
frontline in the coming months so for
all the latest news and details make
sure to follow our social channels and
share your excitement with the community
and the team
that's all for now but we'll have more
updates coming your way in the very near
future we hope you enjoyed what you've
seen so far and we can't wait to show
you more of ghost recon frontline and
once again we wish you all a happy 20th
anniversary ghosts thanks for watching
and see you all very soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you